[Música]
Donald Trump Se declaró No culpable de
los cargos penales que le imputan en el
marco de la causa por mal manejo de
documentos clasificados que fueron
hallados en su residencia de Florida el
republicano enfrenta 37 cargos que
incluyen acusaciones de retención no
autorizada de documentos clasificados y
conspiración para obstruir la justicia
un ataque ruso con misiles mató a 11
personas en la ciudad de ucraniana de y
dejó decenas de heridos el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin le bajó el tono a
los avances de la contraofensiva de
Ucrania y dijo que las pérdidas humanas
de kiev eran 10 veces mayores que las de
Rusia
y la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula Legends continúa su gira por
América Latina y llegó a Argentina donde
se reunió con el presidente Alberto
Fernández Los líderes abordaron temas
como la inversión en materia energética
el acuerdo comercial entre la Unión
Europea y mercosur
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
yo soy María Clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos
iniciamos en Estados Unidos el
expresidente Donald Trump Se declaró No
culpable de los cargos penales que le
imputan en el marco de la investigación
por mal manejo de documentos
clasificados que fueron hallados el año
pasado en su residencia de Florida el
actual precandidato republicano enfrenta
37 cargos que incluyen acusaciones de
retención no autorizada de documentos
clasificados y conspiración para
obstruir la justicia todo ello luego de
que abandonara la Casa Blanca en 2021 se
espera su pronunciamiento para esta
noche los detalles sobre la jornada
clave para Trump desde Miami con nuestro
corresponsal Anthony
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump ya compareció en esta corte
Federal de Miami aquí en Florida donde
se declaró No culpable de los 37 cargos
federales a los que tiene que hacer
frente ahora en este proceso legal llegó
una hora antes de lo previsto y accedió
a un estacionamiento subterráneo para
después tomarse las fotografías y las
huellas dactilares tal y como marcan los
protocolos de esta corte Federal ya en
el interior y con la presencia del juez
de la Fiscalía de los abogados de Donald
Trump Y por supuesto también del ex
mandatario que en ese momento comparecía
bajo arresto se le han leído formalmente
los 37 cargos 31 de ellos tienen que ver
con la ley de espionaje de Estados
Unidos y es que en las pesquisas de Mar
halago donde se Allí se encontraron 31
documentos marcados como secretos o
Ultra secretos Y solo por el hecho de
poseer esos documentos ya es suficiente
para la imputación después de esta
comparecencia Donde ha salido de las
instalaciones de la corte Federal para
poner rumbo a Nueva Jersey donde para
participar en un evento de recaudación
de fondos para su campaña Pues bien
antes ha hecho una parada en el
emblemático restaurante Versalles de
Miami que es el bastión de la comunidad
cubana en el exilio para darse un baño
de masas con Los Seguidores que lo
esperaban allá en los Exteriores en
numerosos simpatizantes se han
congregado desde primera hora de la
mañana para expresar su apoyo a Trump y
denunciar que todo esto forma parte de
una maniobra política para evitar que se
presente a las elecciones de 2024 de
hecho su abogada Alina Java ha dicho
también que este proceso tiene como
objetivo destruir los principios básicos
por los que se rige este país a partir
de ahora empezará un juicio que según
algunos expertos podría alargarse hasta
60 días Si no se llega antes a un
acuerdo o se desestima el caso
pasamos a Ucrania donde varios edificios
Fueron golpeados por un misil Ruso el
ataque ocurrió en la ciudad de kiry en
el centro del país y dejó al menos 11
civiles muertos el informe es de malben
la ciudad de ucranianas siguen bajo
ataque durante la noche un asalto con
misiles rusos golpeó la ciudad de
kribirik en el centro del país un
edificio Residencial fue alcanzado
ha ocurrido una tragedia en la ciudad
varios cohetes cayeron destruyendo
instalaciones industriales algunas
estructuras y viviendas tras horas de
emergencia todavía hay víctimas bajo los
escombros según las autoridades
ucranianas
estábamos durmiendo todas las ventanas
fueron destrozadas aún no entiendo cómo
ocurrió todo al principio hubo un fuerte
estruendo los coches se incendiaron la
ventana de aquí saltó por los aires fue
terrible
Mientras tanto en el terreno de los
combates el ejército ucraniano Afirma
estar avanzando y recuperando
territorios como estos soldados
celebrando la reconquista del pueblo de
macaríptica donde aún persisten algunos
enfrentamientos
desde el sábado cuando fue el anuncio
oficial de la contraofensiva ucraniana 7
aldeas habrían sido reconquistadas según
Jeff un éxito para el presidente
bologylensky
agradezco a nuestros soldados por cada
bandera ucraniana que ahora está
volviendo a su lugar legítimo en los
pueblos del territorio recientemente
liberado
por su parte Moscú considera que la
contraofensiva de kiev ha sido un
fracaso hasta el momento las tropas
rusas mostraron la toma de tanques
leopard donados por Alemania como prueba
de ello y el Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia afirmó que sus tropas han repetido
los avances ucranianos en las regiones
de donets y saporicha y al respecto
habló el presidente incluso Vladimir
Putin quien ofreció un polémico balance
sobre las cifras de las pérdidas humanas
y de armamento por parte de Ucrania
desde que inició la contraofensiva el
mandatario dijo que perdió entre el 25 Y
el 30% de los vehículos militares que le
suministraron los países occidentales y
afirmó además que las pérdidas humanas
de kiev eran 10 veces mayores que las de
Rusia Por otra parte advirtió que estaba
considerando retirarse del acuerdo de
exportación de granos a través del mar
Negro
si tomamos pérdidas irrecuperables está
claro que el lado defensor sufre menos
pérdidas pero aún así esta proporción de
1 a 10 como dicen está a nuestro favor
tenemos 10 veces menos pérdidas que las
fuerzas armadas de Ucrania
pasamos a noticias de América la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
Legend continúa su gira por suelo
latinoamericano y llegó a Argentina
donde se reunió con el presidente de
Alberto Fernández Los firmaron un
memorando de entendimiento centrado en
cadenas de valor de materias primas
sostenibles y abordaron temas como la
inversión en materia energética y el
acuerdo comercial entre la Unión Europea
y mercosur el segundo tema es el de las
materias primas críticas acabamos de
firmar un memorando de entendimiento
sobre esta cuestión es un paso
importante
de Gran calado y creo que serán
beneficios mutuo la demanda Europea de
litio
se espera que crezca 12 veces para 2030
será 12 veces lo que es hoy en 2030 por
los factores que he mencionado pudimos
también tratar otros proyectos que
Argentina tiene dentro del mercosur y
que claramente es por lo que escuché son
del interés de la Unión Europea
fundamentalmente aquello que tiene que
ver con el desarrollo energético
la posibilidad de que Europa se
involucre más activamente en la
producción de litio
en agregarle valor a la producción de
litio a través de la producción de
baterías en la explotación de cobre en
la explotación de hidrógeno verde en
la implementación de plantas
de licuefacción de gas en Guatemala ya
comenzó el plan piloto para solicitar un
permiso Desde allí con el fin de emigrar
a Estados Unidos hace parte de la
política que promueve Washington de lo
que llama una movilidad segura en la que
se eviten las estafas de traficantes de
personas nuestros corresponsal para
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez nos amplía
desde antigua se tiende un puente de
migración legal desde Guatemala hacia
Estados Unidos a partir de esta semana
comenzó el plan piloto con el cual los
nacionales del convenio centroamericano
sea cuatro es decir los ciudadanos de
Guatemala El Salvador Honduras y
Nicaragua podrán solicitar asilo u
obtener una visa para Vivir de manera
legal en Estados Unidos y para ellos ya
está habilitado el portal movilidad
segura.org quienes Allí se inscriban
deberán calificar a una de las vidas
regulares de migración bien sea la de
reunificación Familiar o recordemos la
reciente implementación de la política
migratoria del título ocho deberán
demostrar un verdadero miedo por
persecución política o judicial o de
violencia que es una realidad muy común
que afecta a estos países
Centroamericanos donde están instalados
gobiernos autocráticos donde se denuncia
que hay has hecho judicial donde operan
clandestinamente las pandillas conocidas
como las maras quienes estén inscritos
quienes hayan calificado podrán entonces
agendar una cita presencial en una de
las oficinas de movilidad aquí en
Guatemala exponer su caso aunque esto no
garantiza que les vayan a probar la
migración legal Eso sí hay voces
escépticas como las de los directores de
las oficinas de las casas del migrante
quienes aseguran que se está trasladando
un problema de congestión migratoria que
sufren actualmente México y Estados
Unidos en sus fronteras está viniéndose
entonces para Guatemala y se prevé que
estas oficinas de movilidad seguras se
atibor Ren de migrantes
así llegamos al final de las noticias
nos vemos en minutos en directo América
[Música]